see one of the things that I'm afraid of
one of the things I was always
quitting and my business it's kind of
not a good thing MH every business I
think yours yours is just more uh clear
yeah it it hurts more
and in the moment at least yeah in the
moment but you're right 100% because
some things hurt for a long time after
and um something like regret regret is
the worst thing in the world because
it's a solitary
sentence and and man oh man that's a
powerful phrase regret is a solitary
sentence so boy I you're full of good
lines you know it wasn't easy to uh to
to accumulate
them it was it was a little bit hurtful
but so uh submit less because we submit
every day and if we can get to a place
where we submit or compromise ourselves
less we'll get to a better place you
know again one of the one of the words
for me that attaches to things that give
you that wind up hurting you in life and
have hurt me in life uh one of those
Boogeyman words is the word of
convenience
that's attached to everything you know
PE people
people disappoint you not because they
want to disappoint you or let you down
or betray you because they want to
betray you they do it because it's more
convenient to do than than the other
thing